Trascrizione: Laura Pasquale
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
Buona sera.
Io sono Desiree Prestifilippo
e insegno filosofia e scienze umane.
Il mio argomento di stasera è
PATTERN:
la ripetizione come antidoto all'ansia.
Cominciamo da PATTERN.
PATTERN è un termine
che ha diritto di cittadinanza
in una molteplicità di discipline.
Si usa in informatica,
si usa in architettura, in biologia.
Naturalmente all'interno
di ognuna di queste discipline
l'accezione del termine cambia un pochino.
Significa fondamentalmente
schema, modello.
In informatica si usa per definire
alcuni schemi ricorsivi,
alcuni algoritmi ricorsivi.
In biologia si usa per definire
delle sequenze che si ripetono.
In architettura viene utilizzato,
in design,
per indicare la ripetizione
di un motivo grafico o geometrico,
come in un fregio.
Insomma, il PATTERN
ha a che fare con la ripetizione.
Vedete, questi sono delle realizzazioni
della Wiener Werkstätte,
che utilizzò graficamente moltissimo
il PATTERN.
In moltissimi ambiti artistici,
la scelta di ripetere elementi
diventa una caratterizzazione di stile.
Noi ci occupiamo del PATTERN
nel senso della ripetizione,
della ricorsività,
del ritorno di un'esperienza.
Tenterò di dimostrare che la ripetizione
è funzionale al controllo dell'ansia,
perché riesce a fare diventare noto
qualcosa che percepiamo
come inatteso, inconsueto
e quindi allarmante.
Allora, se nel nostro orizzonte percettivo
compare un elemento
che chiamiamo inconoscibile,
che chiamiamo disturbante,
perché non riusciamo ad assimilarlo
all'interno di nessuno
dei nostri paradigmi di conoscenza,
è sufficiente che questo elemento
ritorni e si ripeta,
perché nell'arco di poco tempo,
all'interno di un breve periodo
di ripetizioni,
abbiamo la sensazione di familiarità,
ragione per cui avremo la sensazione
di comprendere e di conoscere.
Per fare una prova insieme a voi,
ho selezionato due brevi sequenze
tratte dal film che Wim Wenders
ha dedicato
alla danzatrice tedesca Pina Bausch.
Adesso li vediamo insieme,
e poi ve li commenterò.
(Musica, canto e danza)
Il secondo si chiama "Joy".
(Narrazione in spagnolo)
È una bella domanda, ispirava.
(Narrazione in spagnolo continua)
(Musica)
Credo che si colga perfettamente
come la ripetizione del gesto
consenta la comprensione del gesto.
Nella ripetizione, d'altra parte,
il danzatore,
il ginnasta,
il musicista,
supera il limite della difficoltà tecnica
e accede all'interpretazione.
Con la ripetizione, in certi ambiti,
si riesce a giungere
a livelli ulteriori dell'esperienza.
Chiunque abbia danzato
o eseguito un brano musicale
sa che soltanto dopo infinite ripetizioni
la prova diventa veramente libera
dalle pastoie delle difficoltà tecniche.
Questo elemento ci consente di illustrare
un ulteriore aspetto della ripetizione,
diciamo il suo coté mistico,
quello legato alla preghiera.
La preghiera chiede la ripetizione.
La ripetizione si attaglia alla preghiera,
sia nelle grandi tradizioni orientali,
penso alla ripetizione dei mantra
nella tradizione indiana,
che potenzia... la ripetizione potenzia
l'attuazione del mantra,
ma anche nella tradizione cristiana,
la ripetizione del rosario
è funzionale alla sua efficacia.
Alla stessa maniera
avevamo cercato e trovato per proporvela
la danza dei dervisci rotanti,
sono piuttosto dispiaciuta
della qualità del video,
ma è un materiale piuttosto raro.
In questa esperienza, l'orante, il derviscio,
si muove ripetendo,
ripetendo il gesto e ripetendo il canto,
e questa ripetizione,
che ha un effetto quasi ipnotico,
produce livelli alterati di conoscenza,
quasi una trance ipnotica.
E questo è dovuto
esclusivamente alla ripetizione.
In questa danza,
il corpo stesso del derviscio
deve rappresentare una sorta di tramite
tra i due mondi
che collega con la ripetizione
della parola sacra
e col movimento del suo corpo.
È ovvio che ci sono altri ambiti
di applicazione della ripetizione.
Ogni comunicazione persuasiva
si fonda sulla ripetizione.
Non c'è campagna pubblicitaria,
non c'è operazione di marketing,
non c'è organizzazione di propaganda
che non tenga conto della necessaria
ripetizione del messaggio,
senza di che l'efficacia del messaggio
viene fortemente depotenziata.
Mi sembra che questo elemento
sia sufficientemente dimostrato,
e cioè che la ripetizione
dà forza alla cosa che viene ripetuta,
ma soprattutto ce la rende familiare,
e in questo svolge una funzione
rasserenante, calmante,
di maggiore padronanza.
Noi, attraverso la ripetizione,
acquisiamo la padronanza del gesto.
Questo è qualcosa che ci deve fare
abbastanza riflettere.
D'altra parte, è ben comprensibile.
La costruzione dell'identità
è uno dei momenti
più delicati nella esistenza umana
e normalmente solleva ansia.
Abbiamo bisogno di piacere,
abbiamo bisogno di piacerci,
vogliamo trovarci,
ma anche esprimerci,
e cerchiamo il gradimento degli altri.
L'ansia può in questo caso
determinare delle scelte sbagliate.
Voglio sottolineare questo punto:
qui bisogna fare veramente attenzione.
Noi dobbiamo utilizzare la ripetizione,
dobbiamo usarla per quello
che ci può dare.
Ci può dare padronanza,
ci può dare efficacia,
ci può dare la sicurezza
che viene dalla familiarità
con l'evento che consideravamo
non noto e inconsueto.
Ma non dobbiamo fare di noi stessi
dei replicanti.
Ripeto quello che dicevo prima,
per dare forza al mio discorso.
La costruzione dell'identità
è un momento cruciale
nell'esistenza di ogni persona,
e siamo portati a ricercare
il gradimento dell'altro.
Intanto, i mezzi di comunicazione di massa
ci propongono incessantemente
dei modelli omologanti
con la promessa falsa
di un universale gradimento.
La cosa importante è sapere e far sapere
che questa promessa è falsa,
che l'unica possibilità che abbiamo
di realizzare in autonomia e originalità
l'unica vita che abbiamo
è quella di essere pienamente noi stessi.
Per questo motivo vi ho portato
un catalogo,
un catalogo di facce,
un elenco di volti che sono volti noti,
ai quali avrei potuto aggiungere
moltissimi volti non noti,
ma che svolgono
la stessa identica funzione:
quella di ricordarci che abbiamo il dovere
di vivere la nostra vita
in maniera originale,
perché saremo imperfetti ma irripetibili.
Margherita Hack,
Woody Allen,
Annie Leibovitz,
Thomas Mann,
Miriam Makeba,
la Yourcenar,
Giovanotti,
Fernanda Pivano,
Erri De Luca,
Hitchcock,
Patti Smith,
Einstein,
Monica Vitti,
Mandela,
Baudelaire,
che facce....
la signora Levi-Montalcini,
Mick Jagger,
Gae Aulenti,
il mio amico Corto,
Pertini e Bearzot,
Gandhi,
Whoopi,
Fabrizio De André,
Camilleri,
Giorgio Gaber,
Pier Paolo Pasolini,
la Boccassini,
Troisi,
Picasso,
Guccini,
la Callas,
e Anna Magnani
che disse al truccatore:
"Non mi togliere le rughe.
C'ho messo 'na vita a fammele venì!"
Non avevano bisogno di replicare nessuno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)